- I heard that you lost your phone.
I would freak out. Well I have
kids, so I would freak out.
- Listen, I was scrambling.
I don't know if you guys have done this,
but I guess I love my phone.
I don't even notice.
But it was fizzling out of batteries
and something was wrong.
So, sometimes that little
hole in the bottom,
it gets a little fuzz in there,
so it won't, it was losing a charge.
So, I stuck a safety pin
in there to clean it out.
Mistake!
(crowd laughter)
You don't even have to go
to DeVry to know that one.
I was like, (mimics buzzing sound).
- DeVry.
- and then it starts going, "Vuvuvuvu."
And I'm like 36% (humming a tune)
28% going, it's, what
happens when it's over?
It won't charge, so it's done.
It's, so I get to the iPhone
store, and they're like,
"clear" (mimics sound of CPR)
like it's really ICU,
And then they get a
little (buzzing noise).
They get it going.
But man for 16 hours, that
should be the internet challenge.
16 hours I did not have my phone.
I don't even know how to drive,
(crowd laughter) without.
I was like,
- You didn't know where to go?
- What do I just look at (beep)?
You know what I mean?
(laughter)
I'm like, where do I put my
hands on the steering wheel?
(laughter and applause)
Hey, there's trees on my street.
- (laughing) Trees on my street...
- I know I go, look, you
guys, there's trees all over.
(crowd laughter)